>> And I'm thrilled to welcome David Plouffe
to Google.
David spent the last two decades helping get
Democratic candidates elected to public office.
And as many of you know, he was Barack Obama's
campaign manager during the primary and general
election in 2008.
David's leadership style exemplifies many
of the qualities we value here at Google:
He's data-driven.
He has a laser-like focus on the user or,
in his case, the voter.
He challenges the status quo.
And he lets the results of his work speak
for him.
With those qualities, David built a billion-dollar
startup that accomplished what the vast majority
of the world said was simply impossible.
He's written an excellent book, "The Audacity
to Win."
And we're thrilled to have David here at Google
today.
Thank you for coming.
>> [Clapping]
David Plouffe: Thank you, Glenn.
Can you guys hear me? Okay.
Glenn, actually, used to work with my wife,
who plays a number of starring roles in the
book.
So it was a big part of helping our family
survive way back when.
It's good to be with you guys.
I don't want to prattle on too much here,
so we have time for discussion.
So I thought I would just highlight some of
the main --
>> [inaudible]
David Plouffe: Yeah, oh my goodness.
[laughter] I like avoiding videocameras, so
-- but that was not purposeful.
Some of the main sort of principles that thread
throughout the book.
Obviously, if you guys want to end the discussion,
we can talk about some of the great characters
and moments of the campaign -- you know, Reverend
Wright and Bill Ayers and Joe the Plumber
and Sarah Palin, or anything that's on your
mind today.
And I think one of the important things about
the book is -- as we're in another one of
those moments when Washington is kind of in
a frenzy and misreading things -- I think
it's good to remind of the stability in the
approach in the leadership style of the president
as he keeps his eye firmly focused on the
goal, not kind of the furor in politics of
the moment, which was really one of the reasons
we won the election.
I'd start by saying, One of the big principles
-- both of the book and our campaign -- was
that we were successful in large measure because
we defied convention.
Probably something that you guys try and live
and breathe every day here.
But we were a startup business in the beginning.
Barack Obama was highly unusual.
And that almost everybody who runs for president
in both parties has planned to do it for years.
They spend time in Iowa, New Hampshire, and
they build up fundraising apparatus.
Nowadays, you build up e-mail lists.
We started this campaignn with nothing. Nothing.
He hadn't even had a competitive Senate race.
So he hadn't gone around the country and raised
money like most people do.
And as hard as that was -- and it was hard
in every way imaginable -- we had to, you
know, get bank accounts set up and figure
out our computer system and office space and
who was going to staff and get familiar with
the states that were going to determine our
fate.
We profited from that period, because we did
not have a dusty playbook on the shelf about
how we -- or anyone -- should run for president
in the year 2008.
And so, throughout the book, I highlight areas
where we defied the convention.
And there are big examples of that and small
examples of that.
Probably the biggest one is the reason we
won -- is that we tried to do something that
rarely has anyone in politics achieved, certainly
at the presidential level -- was that, we
tried to change the electorate.
We tried to change our consumer base.
And that wasn't just an idea, it was a necessity
for us.
We simply would not have won the Democratic
primary had the people who always came out
to vote in primaries and caucuses done so.
We had to make it younger and more diverse
and had to get independents and Republicans
to participate.
And it was a really, really hard thing to
do.
And we won the Iowa caucuses, which takes
up a big part of the book -- almost entirely
based on expansion of the electorate, you
know?
People over 65 had historically turned out
at twice the rate of people under 30 in Iowa
caucuses every time it had been held.
And we changed that.
And on election night in Iowa, as many people
turned out under 30 as over 65.
That's why we won.
And if we had lost Iowa, Barack Obama would
have been a small footnote in political history.
It meant everything to us, and we kept our
eyes focused on that prize.
And you know, by the way, Google played a
role in that.
Because we found out that these voters -- younger
voters, people who had been checked out of
politics, people who might vote in general
elections but not primaries -- they needed
basic information.
It needed to be very easy for them to find
out where to participate.
And one thing we did in Iowa, and then it
worked -- and we did it in every primary and
caucus, and Hillary Clinton did not.
And then, we did in the general election;
John McCain did not -- was, we did a lot of
advertising just so that it would be easy
for people to find out where to participate.
You know, a lot of states with caucuses and
primaries, we had a look-up tool that people
came in through Google -- just a basic look-up
tool.
"I live here, where do I participate?" No
one else was providing that service. No one.
Not Democratic parties, not election officials
-- at least, not easily.
I think it enabled us to have probably produced
millions of additional votes in the general
election.
And so, we learned not to forget about the
blocking and tackling.
Because these people did not know how and
when to participate.
And that was the thread that carried us all
the way through the general election.
Was, Don't just focus on the poetry and the
music and all the, you know, great rhetoric;
get them there.
Because, obviously, if they did not vote -- and
there were people, if something happened to
them -- they got busier at work, a child care
issue -- they were the people least likely
to vote.
And so, in a lot of states out west, of course,
we don't have Election Day anymore.
We have Election Month. We have Early Vote.
And that's what we focused on -- back to Glenn's
point about data.
I didn't care about the raw numbers in Early
Vote.
What I cared about is, Are we voting those
less-frequent, young voters?
Are we turning them out?
Because those are the people you didn't want
to have to wait on Election Day to see if
they came out.
You wanted to get their vote in the bank.
So that's a big thread -- the change in the
electorate.
And listen, the general election ended up
not being close.
We assumed it would be. Historically, it is.
But on Election Day, we won.
The people who voted in the Bush/Kerry election
in '04, the margin was Obama 50, McCain 49.
Absolute dead heat.
And of course, the electoral colleges, we've
learned, would have been close as well.
But amongst those people voting in their first
election -- or their first election in a long
time -- we won 71 to 27, sixty percent of
those people under thirty.
You may never see another number like that
in the history of American politics.
That that big of an advantage in that cohort.
So that was the big defying of convention
that we did.
And of course, what made it hard is, the political
commentators, the pundits, the media -- fortunately,
our opponents -- didn't believe it could happen.
Did not believe it could happen. And that
was hard.
Because we had to muscle through and convince
people that we had the right strategy.
Our belief that we could win states like North
Carolina, Indiana, Virginia, even Florida,
was a big part of our success.
You know, politics is a competition.
And we dictated the campaign to John McCain.
Because, by the end, he was worrying more
about holding on to those Bush states that
they swore weren't going to be competitive
than trying to beat us in Kerry states like
Wisconsin, Pennsylvania etc.
So, it's a chess match.
And by the end of the election, we had checkmated
the king, because we were dictating the terms
of the debate to him.
And one thing I hope, if you read the book
-- those of you that do -- you'll learn is,
the election is not as it's portrayed commonly
in the media. Okay?
It's not about the clever ad that you put
on TV or the national polls or even state
polls, okay?
The way we viewed the election was, It's a
puzzle to get to 270 electoral votes.
And beneath that kind of topline puzzle is
your theory of how you're going to win the
states to get you to 270.
And that's what we lived and breathed every
day.
We had a theory of how we're going to win
every state.
Okay, How many people do we have to register
in North Carolina?
How many Republicans do we have to get?
How many Independents?
How many women between the ages of 25 and
50 with a college degree do we need to win?
All of that. And that's what we tracked.
And the way we were able to track it is, we
had volunteers out there doing millions of
contacts every day so that we were getting
data back.
And that was our Bible; that was our north
star -- not any of the stuff that was really
talked about ad nauseam publicly.
So that was a big risk.
We also believed strongly in two areas: both
grassroots volunteer work and technology -- that
you really can't talk about one without the
other.
And combined and married together, they became
one of the most powerful forces in political
history in this country.
And you know, the reason it worked for us
was that -- from the very, very beginning,
most political campaigns -- and I would argue
still too many private sector companies -- do
not have those two things: Technology and
the power of people talking to people at the
core of their mission. And we did. Okay?
We were going to be a grassroots campaign.
We're going to lose.
And our theory was, "So many people in their
lives live all, or most of it, through technology."
And if their intersection with our campaign
was somehow an exception to that -- as politics
normally was; people did not use the digital
space to do much more than raise money -- we
would lose.
And we did not try and set out to build the
best political website in the field or even
in history.
Our view -- and we got a lot of great guidance
from people out in this area of the country
who, when no one else was for us -- there
weren't a lot of people jumping on the Barack
Obama bandwagon in the beginning, but a lot
of people in your field were.
And so, our view was, "Well, we have to have
a website and a social networking site that
-- when people are on Amazon or they're searching
on Google or they're on Facebook, whatever
site they're on, NewYorkTimes.com -- their
experience with us can't be terribly deficient.
If it is, they're never going to come back.
And I think that's the way you have to look
at it.
And we tried to build a website that became
a home for people so that they could do anything
they wanted to there for us -- organize for
us, raise money for us, get information.
We tried to drive people there to watch big
moments in the campaign.
You might remember when we announced our vice
presidential pick, we did it by text message.
But in that text message, we said, "We've
picked Joe Biden.
Watch the first event, Saturday at two o'clock
on Barack Obama.com."
Not on TV. On our website.
And it became a home for people.
And our social networking site became a very,
very powerful thing, where millions of people
got involved in a campaign and organized in
their states for us long before we had a staff
person on the ground.
You know, some of the smartest things we did
in the campaign were just, Stay out of people's
way and let them do their thing -- and they
did their thing.
And that's why we were able to beat Hillary
Clinton in the primary in places where she
had all the political support and 30 point
leads.
It's because we had people on the ground in
Durango, Colorado and in St. Paul, Minnesota
and in Mobile, Alabama, organizing for us.
Long before I even focused on it, they were
making it happen.
And then, once we got on the ground, we were
able to really focus things.
So the grassroots and technology played such
an enormous role.
Now, it obviously helped us fund our campaign.
That's the thing the press and observers pay
a lot of attention to -- and it was important.
Money matters in politics.
We raised 750 million, 500 million of it online.
Most of that from average Americans -- four
million of them -- who gave us an average
of $85.
We've never seen that before in politics.
We didn't take any money from lobbyists or
PACs.
We took it from people.
And almost all of those people volunteered.
And we tried to build campaigns, and I talk
a lot about this in the book.
We tried to build campaigns in each battleground
state that, in and of themselves, could help
deliver us victory.
So in the state of Florida or the state of
Ohio, or the state of North Carolina, we decided,
"What is everything that we can humanly do
to win this election?" So in Florida, it was
$38 million.
Think about that, you know?
That is probably -- by a factor of ten -- more
money than has ever been spent in Florida
in presidential politics. State after state.
And you know, it was down to the dollar, and
we actually shared those budgets with our
donors so they understood what the money was
going to.
It wasn't just a black hole.
We tried to build trust with people so that
they understood, when they were giving time
or money, what it meant.
And I think any organization that's trying
to get people to give time -- whether it's
in Google and they're asking you to do something
outside of your normal course of business
or nonprofits or political campaigns -- you've
got to explain to people how what they're
doing fits into the overall message.
And that's what we did.
And so, when someone went out there and knocked
on doors for four hours and registered 12
voters in Raleigh, North Carolina, they understood
what it meant.
Because they said, "Okay, I've been told to
win North Carolina.
We have to register 200,000 people.
And I just did my part and hundreds of people
like me today did."
So the money was important, but what the grassroots
did -- only enabled by technology -- was,
it organized our campaign, okay?
In ways big and small.
And I talked about expansion of the electorate.
We always believed that the best way to get
somebody to vote -- obviously, they had to
have some interest in Obama, some belief in
him.
But we always thought the most likely reason
a 45-year-old African-American man in Philadelphia
would register and vote for the very first
time was because his friend or his family
member was going to do so, and said, "I'm
going to register and vote.
You should too."
Why did so many young people get involved?
It was almost always because one of their
friends was getting involved and said, "Hey,
I'm going to go down to the Obama office in
Durango, Colorado.
Why don't you join me?" And so, the grassroots
movement out there registered the voters,
persuaded the voters, recruited the volunteers.
And it wasn't just the numbers.
We had more volunteers than we've ever seen
in American political history and may ever
again, except for 2012.
It was who they were that made a difference.
When I -- or any of you, who have a known
political persuasion, talks about politics
with our friends or family members or colleagues,
no one listens to what we say, because they
already know what we're going to say.
But 50 percent of our people had never been
involved in politics before -- had never given
time or money to a campaign.
So when they talk about politics, people lean
in a little bit more closely.
Say, "John, I've never heard you care about
politics. I want to listen."
20 percent of our core volunteers were Republicans
and Independents.
So when a Republican says, "I've never voted
for a presidential candidate who's a Democrat
going all the way back to John F Kennedy,
I voted for Richard Nixon in that race, but
I'm voting for Obama -- let me tell you why."
People want to listen to that.
So it was the diversity, not just in age or
ethnicity, but in those people who hadn't
been involved in politics who we thought were
so powerful.
And then, there were message deliverers -- and
this is something you guys understand better
than I do.
You know, it wasn't too long ago in this country
where -- if you did a press conference or
spoke to several network and cable news anchors,
you were reaching most of the voters in this
country.
Obviously, not anymore.
Particularly, the expansion electorate we're
talking about.
They do not watch cable news -- any of them.
None of them. None of them.
They very rarely watch the networks.
They certainly don't read the national news.
And they don't always get information online.
Some of it is they just talk to each other
through e-mail, through social networking,
through phone calls, from conversations.
And that's what we believed in: That there's
no more powerful communication -- whether
it's to get someone to try a new brand or
a new product, or to consider voting for someone
-- than a human being talking to a human
being.
And ideally, it's someone from their community,
someone they grew up with, someone that's
lived on their block their whole life.
Particularly when you knew we were going to
get attacked in very personal and character-based
ways.
The best way to convince, you know, the independent
diner owner from Indiana that Obama wasn't
trying to, you know, completely destroy the
tax system here and, you know, was going to
protect America and did see America like we
all did, unlike what Sarah Palin said, was
to have someone on that block say, "I've looked
into this.
Don't believe it. Let me tell you the truth."
Okay?
And that was something that got very little
attention in the campaign, but it made all
the difference in the world.
And technology allowed us to do that, because
on a day that Joe the Plumber, you know, arrives
on the scene, the debate for a period of days
was about tax cuts and "Was Barack Obama socialist
or not?" -- as silly as that is, okay?
So it doesn't do any good if our volunteer
on the ground in Ohio is talking about health
care when the debate for the moment has turned
to tax cuts.
Now, in a campaign, it's easy for us to say,
"Okay, this is what Barack Obama is going
to say today.
This is what Joe Biden is going to say today.
This is what people like I are going to say
today."
It's harder to get 13 million people on the
same message.
But we're able to do that obviously through
e-mail -- some texting -- so that people were
as current in the campaign as any of us were.
And that was probably the hardest thing we
did, but it was really important.
And to make sure we were in alignment -- something
I talk a lot in the book about.
And I think -- I look at a lot of people who
are trying to communicate today, and they're
not in full alignment.
And what does that mean?
Well, from our standpoint, it meant: If Barack
Obama was in Denver, Colorado giving a speech
about health care -- the television ad, the
radio ad, the Internet advertising, the e-mails,
and the volunteers at the door and on the
phones, better be talking about health care
that day.
Because if you are not in alignment and you're
not compounding your message activities, you
are missing a huge opportunity.
And I'm amazed at how many people are communicating
today where they'll have a new TV campaign
or the CEO is giving a speech and the digital
messaging is not in alignment.
In today's world, you never know how you're
going to reach somebody.
It's really, really hard.
And our view was, you had to fill every space
and you had to be saying the same thing.
And that meant in a battleground state -- and
those of you living in San Francisco, or the
area -- you did not witness the presidential
campaign.
But if you lived in Terre Haute, Indiana or
Roanoke, Virginia, you did.
And we tried to be obviously on your television,
broadcast and cable, on demand -- we did a
lot of on demand and got millions and millions
of people watching lengthier programming.
That was a huge asset.
We were all over radio, including on traditional
radio. A lot of faith radio.
A lot of radio that sports men and women listen
to, to go right after McCain and his base.
We did an enormous amount of Internet advertising
obviously, more so than anyone had ever done
as a balance.
But we also wanted to be at community events.
We wanted to be at your doors.
We wanted to be in your e-mail and your cell
phone -- not to annoy you, but you never know
when you're going to be able to capture somebody.
And so, that's got to be compounded.
So that's a thread of the book in the campaign
that I think was really, really important.
And then, last thing I'll say on a big point
was -- and you know, this maybe crossing into
kum bah yah land, but -- you guys are an entity
that believes in culture of the organization
and we did too.
And first of all, the volunteers in our campaign
were extension of our staff.
We didn't, you know, it wasn't like the volunteers
are a nice addition.
They were our campaign.
We made strategic decisions based on what
we thought they could mean to the campaign.
We wouldn't have targeted Indiana and North
Carolina, for instance, if we didn't have
a strong enough grassroots campaign, because
we thought there was no way we could win either
one of those states without what we had on
the ground.
So we had a great communication network and
esprit de corps with our volunteers, starting
with Barack Obama.
You know, there was a lot of discussion of,
"Okay, well.
What you guys did with technology with volunteers,
other campaigns should do that."
Well, I happen to think everybody running
for office should try and get people involved
in our campaign.
But it's not that easy. You can't manufacture
this.
The reason it worked is, Barack Obama had
a relationship with 13 million Americans.
And it strengthened and solidified so that
they got inspired to give time they did not
have to give and money they did not have to
give.
And the tactics and the technologies and the
tools and the strategies would have been pointless
without that.
But that relationship was strong, and we trusted
them.
And I think most of our volunteers really
believed that Barack Obama and his campaign
really believed in them -- that what they
were doing mattered.
But also, you know, for all of us in the campaign,
you know -- campaigns are tough.
And we went through moments of great challenge
and triumph.
All of '07, no one thought we could win.
We lose the New Hampshire primary; it looked
like we had lost our chance.
We go through the Reverend Wright thing, which
was deeply challenging.
Obviously dealing with the furor around Palin
challenged us as well.
And he was at his calmest and his best and
his most dogged during those moments.
And calmness kind of infiltrated the entire
organization.
And I can't tell you how important that is.
And I think it's important today, as you're
trying to sort through all the challenges,
and -- I would still argue -- huge opportunities
we have in this country, if we only have the
courage to take advantage of them.
That calmness -- which should not be mistaken
for a lack of urgency -- was really important.
The other thing: We were very metrics-driven.
And we had strategy/message, which were the
two pillars of any political campaign.
Google probably has different pillars.
For us, it's, "What's your electoral strategy?
What's your message?"
We were not a democracy in that regard.
And that's what we were going to do.
We weren't arrogant.
We weren't sure they'd work, but our view
was, you had to commit yourself to a path.
Campaigns are short.
What's your path? What's your theory of success
and stick to it.
And we tried to educate people in the campaign
-- from senior staff down to the volunteer
what that was, so that decision making became
uneventful.
As a leader, that's the thing I'm most interested
in, by the way -- making decision-making uneventful.
So that there's clarity on things.
Things either support your strategy and your
message or they don't.
So 98 percent of the things that cross your
desk are easy yes's or no.
And people in the organization did understand
why.
Even if they disagree, they understand that
there's a theory behind it.
And it is not subjective.
And we were that way in terms of measuring
performance.
And you guys are more into data than I am,
but we measured people's performance in the
campaign -- by the way, including volunteers.
We had to relieve some volunteers of their
duty, because we weren't getting the job done.
But it was based on numbers.
How much money were we supposed to raise in
this city this day?
How many volunteers were we supposed to recruit?
What kind of press coverage were we supposed
to get in the local market?
How many votes were we supposed to bank today?
All of that was laid out.
So that, as we viewed the campaign, we didn't
say, "Hey, we had a good day today, because
the pundits on CNN said we did."
We had a good day today, because we hit our
metrics in most places.
And so then, when we're able to talk to -- when
we had to have conversations with people about
their performance, they could be done in a
very, very objective fashion.
And if we needed a course-correct, I think
our employees understood that it wasn't based
on some subjective thought about their performance.
It was based on cold, hard numbers.
So none of that's as exciting as, you know,
dealing with Sarah Palin or, you know, some
of the advertising we did.
But politics, at the end of the day, is about
a lot of blocking and tackling.
It's about having a clear strategy.
Now, none of the stuff I've mentioned matters,
obviously, if you don't have a wonderful candidate.
And that's the thing that really threads through
the book most importantly of all is that -- someone
who had never been on this national political
stage, who every time he went to a county
or a town in Iowa, New Hampshire, South Carolina,
it was always the first time he had been there
his entire life.
And never had a negative ad run against him.
Had never been through a tough, rigorous proctological
exam by the press. [laughter]
None of these things had happened.
And yet, over a two-year period, in what is
a flawed process in many ways: You could say,
"It's too long. It's too expensive." It can
be too banal.
It is enormously transparent, particularly
with technology where people can fire up their
computers and watch any video, any interview,
any speech a candidate's given.
And increasingly, that will be done on mobile
devices.
You cannot hide who you are.
And over that two-year period, he built a
grassroots movement and fed it and nourished
it, the likes of which we'd never seen.
He ran that obstacle course, which is highly
brutal, and grew in stature for the American
people.
Most people diminish over time in a campaign
like that. He grew.
And at the moments of greatest crisis -- Reverend
Wright, losing New Hampshire, the economic
crisis, McCain saying he's not going to debate.
All these moments.
We couldn't take a poll to decide how to deal
with it.
It was his instincts and judgments and performance
that led us out of the wilderness.
And so, I think that's something that comes
through clearly in the book is that, you know,
I think there's far too much attention paid
to our campaign in terms of the tactics and
the strategy.
None of that matters without a candidate who
met his time and met his moment.
And that's what we had in president Obama.
So with that, I'd be happy to entertain anything
you guys have on your mind.
And don't be shy. Yes, sir.
Q Just wondering how the campaign tactics
differ between a caucus state and a non-caucus
state?
David Plouffe: Difference between caucus and
non-caucus state.
Well, very different.
Obviously, caucuses historically have lower
turn out.
How many of you have been to a caucus?
Wow. What state?
Q I was a volunteer down at Texas.
David Plouffe: Texas caucus.
Well, caucus basically in most states, you've
got to show up at one time -- so 6:30, 7:00.
You separate into groups -- publicly -- so
your neighbors are there.
And you go in the corner.
Here's the Obama group.
Here's the Clinton group.
Here's the Edwards group.
So you publicly state your preference.
And then, in most states, if your candidate
doesn't get 15 percent of the people in that
group, then you get to vote twice essentially.
So you've got to know who's everybody's second
choice is.
In a lot of states, like Iowa, they also conduct
party business before you get to the voting.
So someone's got to make like, a two-hour
commitment to be there.
That's why turn out is really low.
Now, there became a mythology that caucuses
were our territory and primaries were hers.
I can tell you in every state where there
were caucuses -- our initial polling, we were
getting clobbered.
And had the people who normally turned out
in caucuses turned out, we would have gotten
clobbered.
Caucuses were where we had to expand the electorate.
Now, because turn out had been so low, you
had a greater ability to expand the electorate,
because in a primary, you can only go from,
let's say, here to here.
And caucus you go from here to here.
So that's what we set out to do.
So the expansion of the electorate.
And then, it's organizing.
I mean, you've got to be on people -- like
white on rice, all the way through -- to make
sure they go.
And we did a lot of demystifying of the caucus
for people.
We put out videos.
We did trainings to say, "It's not as bad
as you think.
Just show up and everything will be okay."
And so, you have to have -- there are people
called 'precinct captains'.
There are volunteers, okay?
There are people who are teachers.
People who work at Google.
People who run businesses who say, "I will
be the Obama precinct captain, and I will
take responsibility for convincing the people
in my precinct to support him to turn out.
And on caucus night, I will run that precinct.
I will have it organized."
It's an enormous amount of responsibility
for a volunteer.
And so, it's very different.
I happen to think caucuses are wonderful,
because I believe in grassroots politics.
I think it made us a stronger campaign in
the general, because we were so organized.
You have to organize in every precinct.
So that was the difference.
Yes, sir.
Q So you were talking about how you have this
huge network of supporters to react really
quickly to topics -- [inaudible]
David Plouffe: Sure. Well, one of the things
we tried to do was -- Listen, there would
be moments of the campaign where we were leaning
into a health care comparison with McCain
or a debate on diplomacy with Hillary Clinton,
and then we wanted everybody in the campaign
to be talking about that. Okay?
Back to my point about alignment.
But one thing we tried to do -- even in moments
like that -- but just general like, when we
were in Iowa, and we were trying to build
in Iowa -- the thing we tell people is -- who
said, "Well, I've decided to support Obama."
They tell us.
"Well, go get more people to support Obama."
"But what do you want me to say?" "Well, say
what you're going to say, because if you're
reading off some script, it's not going to
be authentic."
It's always more authentic when someone speaks
from here.
And so, even on health care, we wanted them
to be able to have the best sentence down
about Obama's health care plan and how it
differed with McCain.
But it was always best if they said, "And
listen, I care about this, because my sister
was denied coverage by the insurance companies.
And we have to get change now."
That was always more powerful than a stale
script.
So we did something a little bit unusual.
We encouraged people to speak from their heart
-- to not be automatons.
And obviously, we did a lot of user-generated
-- both, you know, text commentary and video
commentary throughout the campaign.
And it was a great way for people to express
themselves.
And it also -- there was an authenticity to
it.
One of the things we did -- we shared a lot
of videos and other -- we captured a lot of
the work that was going on out there in the
country and shared it with people.
Because not everybody who was out there volunteering
in Anderson, Indiana would necessarily, you
know, I think relate to what I was doing on
a given day or David Axelrod, but they relate
to what the volunteer in Denver, Colorado
was doing and say, "Hey. Boy, they put on
a great canvas. I can do that too."
So we tried to let a thousand flowers bloom
and let people talk from the heart.
And even in our advertising -- and this was
a challenge, because some of the firms that
we brought in to work with us, you know, they
were used to kind of scripting everybody.
"This is what I want the person to say." And
we didn't want that to happen.
People always put things in a more compelling
way if you just let them talk.
And it always sounds less political.
So when we did ads with people in them, we
just let them talk.
And you know, it was always better than if
we had said, "Hey, why don't you say this?"
Always better.
And you know, Listen, authenticity -- people's
B.S. meter is highly sensitized, particularly
younger voters. Particularly younger voters.
And you guys probably find this.
And if we were not dealing authentically,
you know, they'd let us know.
And that's why, if you look at the videos
we did throughout the campaign -- I'm just
talking about videos that we e-mailed out
to people, to our supporters, to get them
motivated -- whether they were from me or
from Barack Obama -- they weren't scripted.
You know, he'd come off the stage at a rally
just talk to the camera.
You know, we have some sense of, "Hey, we're
doing a big voter registration effort."
Or Early Vote effort.
So he'd talk about that, but then, he'd just
talk.
And I do the same thing.
And you know, I did one where -- I remember
the first couple I did, I just did them on
a Mac laptop camera and, you know, a couple
of people in the campaign said, "Hey, you
know, Plouffe, we're running for president
and you look like your in the hostage video.
[laughter] You know.
Can we professionalize this up a little bit?"
So we tried one where we went to an office
and lit it and shot it with an HD camera,
and our supporters hated it.
Because it was like propaganda to them.
They wanted to be let in the campaign.
They wanted me to roll out a debate prep at
2 a.m. in the morning and flew to Ohio, kind
of groggy-eyed and speaking to the camera
about what was going on.
And so, we learned a lot from that -- that
authenticity you know.
And listen, at the core, remember Barack Obama
was challenged a lot in the campaign.
He doesn't speak enough in sound bites.
He's trusting voters to have an adult conversation,
of all things.
He's too professorial.
Now, he wasn't going to change who he was,
because he said, "This is who I am." that
authenticity.
I think candidates always get in difficulty
when they kind of adjust something core to
who they are.
And we had a candidate who that just wasn't
a debate.
Whether it would have been a smart thing to
do or not, it just wasn't entertainment.
Yes, sir.
Q Two questions. One, what do you think happened
this summer when the conservatives I would
say won the grassroots effort on health care
[inaudible]?
David Plouffe: Well first, I would heavily
disagree with the notion that they won.
People on Fox and CNN were talking about them.
That's not reality, okay?
Reality is what is happening on the ground
throughout the country.
And I think that, in the campaign, the truth
is, the organizing that we did that is so
kind of mythologized now, it wasn't appreciated
during the campaign.
It wasn't until people saw the election results.
They said, "Hey, all those volunteers actually
made a difference."
And what happened -- and we have been organizing
on health care going back to the spring.
We've had millions of Americans making phone
calls, sending out e-mails, you know, visiting
Congress.
Now, some of the tea-baggers in a few town
halls, you know, the truth is, this is not
an interesting story to the media.
Eighty supporters of Barack Obama showed up
at a town hall today to express support for
health care.
In their view, "Boring."
But people yelling and screaming, that's exciting.
So, but if you look at health care reform,
it has remained remarkably stable in terms
of support, okay?
Now, there's a lot of people opposed to it,
a lot of people supporting it.
The components of it actually have grown in
support.
Why is that?
Because if you look at historical health care
reform efforts -- whether it was Bill Clinton,
whether it was Richard Nixon, whether it was
Harry Truman, whether it was both Roosevelts.
You know, by this time health care reform
had been stripped bare because of all the
attacks.
And support for health care has remained pretty
stable.
Why is that? Because my view is, people are
talking to each other about this.
And they're saying, "Okay, death panels. Do
we believe it or not? We don't."
"Am I not going to be able to see my doctor
anymore?
Well, let me think about that. Let me share
information. I don't think so."
So I think they did a good job of capturing
the media's attention, but I don't think structurally.
And listen, the members of Congress -- certainly
the Democratic members of Congress -- know
what's happening on the ground.
The vast, vast majority of them have heard
from our side on this.
The vast majority of town halls were flooded
with people supporting health care reform.
So I think they did some clever tactically
things.
I don't think that what you're seeing right
now, by the way -- the canvassing, the phone
calling -- it's not happening on the other
side.
So they did a good job of kind of capturing
the fascination of the media, but I don't
think structurally.
For me, personally, you know I have a young
family -- we went through two years, as everyone
else did in the administration.
Everyone had to make their personal decision.
It just didn't make sense for me.
I had an infant daughter born two days after
the election on top of our son.
I just couldn't go in for two years. Maybe
longer.
I mean, I don't really have a huge desire
to work in the White House.
I have a huge desire to help him.
I'm under no illusions that, at some point,
I'm probably going to -- the gig will be up
and I'll have to hand back over my life and
I'll be happy to do so.
So I'm just doing what I can on the outside
for a couple of years, and then we'll see.
But I think, listen, the truth is -- You know,
it's funny, I was on a radio show here earlier
today with Ron Owens.
And he was playing some clips of Obama's speeches
during the campaign.
And it is remarkable that he is trying to
do exactly what he said he was going to do.
And there is a belief out there that it should
be easier than it is.
But let me tell you something.
The reason he ran for president was, he believed
on health care and energy -- to some extent
on education.
Washington was failing the country.
If we do not stop spending twice as much money
on health care as our competitors, if we do
not lead on green technology and jobs -- as
we did in the industrial, information revolution
-- and, if we don't reform our education
system, 25, 50 years from now, there is no
guarantee this country -- the United States
of America -- will be as strong as it is today
or has been.
We have to renew ourselves.
And Washington wasn't getting the job done,
because Washington is very short-term.
It's very political.
It's always easy to say, "No, not this year.
Not now."
And that's what he's delivering on.
And this is a really, really hard thing to
do.
Because think about it: As he's trying to
triage the economy, along with the private
sector obviously, he's trying to do these
long-term structural things.
Long-term, meaning the benefits of health
care are going to take a long time to settle
in.
The investments in energy are going to take
some time to materialize.
The education changes take some time to materialize.
So you're asking Congress and the country
to do things that the positive benefit won't
be apparent in the next election, or the one
after that, or the one after that.
And that's what Washington has refused to
do.
So I think that one of his strengths, by the
way, is during August -- during the 'tea bag'
moment -- we went through some tough moments
in the campaign where the kind of commentariat
questioned us.
He and his organization do not view their
success or failures through the prism of that.
They have goals.
They have metrics internally that they're
trying to get to.
Because if you govern based on the kind of
politics of the moment -- listen, Fox News
is doing well ratings-wise.
But let's remember this -- their average viewership
at night, so during the the great you know,
three hours of Reilly and Beck and van Sustren,
it's only two and a half million people.
Think about that. 140 million people voted
in the elections.
Less than two percent of the election. That
is not reality.
But it is viewed as reality in Washington.
And so, it's something you have to have a
lot of discipline and strength not to overreact
to, in my view. Yeah.
Q So I think education and health care are
two of the _____ spinned by most of the time.
I was definitely an Obama supporter after
the primary.
But one thing, after watching the debates,
that all the candidates seem to have a very
similar view on was same sex marriage.
For me, I thought [inaudible] I was kind of
surprised that McCain had the same position
on that.
Can you talk about, you know, [inaudible]
David Plouffe: Question about same sex marriage.
Well listen, I think most candidates in both
parties had the same view.
You know, in the president's case and Hillary
Clinton's case and most of our Democrat competitors,
it was full rights, but, you know, personally
not supportive of marriage.
You know, my personal view is, this is something
that, you know, there's a generational divide.
And you look at people under 30 -- Republicans,
Independents, and Democrats -- and you know,
support levels obviously are much, much higher.
I do think, by the way, you don't see some
of these social issues driving other elections
like they used to.
And I think that's a positive development.
So people say, "I may have a strong feeling
about gay marriage one way or the other, guns,
abortion, but I'm not necessarily going to
cast my vote for president or senator or governor
based on that."
And I think that's a good development.
Partially because I think, you know, we're
facing some really serious challenges.
People are feeling it in their lives.
So, I do think, you know, signing hate crimes
legislation that had language for ten years
is really important.
There's been some really important reforms
made in terms of federal law and employment
around the rights of same sex partners.
And I think we just have to continue to make
progress, but it's really hard.
And you know, it's a civil rights issue.
So I think people are right to be impatient.
But we've got that. We've got huge crises
around the world brewing.
We've obviously got an economic calamity the
likes of what we haven't seen since the Great
Depression.
And it is truth is, everywhere is feeling
it.
But, you know, for those of you that have
been out in the middle part of the country,
you know it's -- these people are feeling
it.
You've got unemployment rates in some of these
communities of 15, 18, 20, 22.
And you know, this is big stuff.
And they've lost health care.
And because the economy has changed in fundamental
ways and the job market has, in a lot of these
communities, you know, there is no easy pathway.
It's not just, "Okay, the economy is going
to bounce back, and then, I'll get rehired."
So this is really tough stuff they're dealing
with.
And you know he's getting accused of -- by
some people -- of not doing enough things.
By many other people, of trying to do too
much.
And so, it's hard to please everybody, but
I can assure you this.
He did not run -- is that? [pause] I'll use
the podium. [pause]
You'd probably expect me to say this, but
he did not run for the presidency to occupy
that office, or to win reelection as a central
principle.
It was to try and tackle tough problems.
And not everyone's going to agree.
Many people won't agree with everything he's
doing -- his priorities, the specific policy
solutions.
But I think that's going to serve the country
well.
Because otherwise, you're going to get cowed,
and you're not going to think long-term, and
we've had too much of that in Washington already.
Yes, sir.
Q [undecipherable]
David Plouffe: No, he would. I mean, I think
that some of the e-mail messages we sent out,
he would look at them all.
He wrote a few. He edited most.
Listen, he was the best writer in our campaign
in a campaign full of great writers.
He's one of the best writers in the country,
in my view.
So, you know, he obviously authored most of
our important speeches.
But yeah, he would.
And he would often say, you know, particularly,
you know, he was out there with people.
So he'd be in a state, and volunteers would
come up to him and say, "You know what?
I keep getting these e-mails about how you
won't salute the flag or, you know, you're
a Muslim or all these things.
And you know, the campaign's not making it
easy enough for us to respond."
So sometimes he'd come back with feedback
and say, "Hey, you know.
Why don't we make an adjustment on the website
so it's easier for people?" Now, he's someone
who lives a lot of his life through technology.
So that was really terrific.
Because, you know, he was online all the time
and he had a lot of interaction with our volunteers.
So yeah, he provided us a lot of guidance
in that regard.
Yes.
Q I'm hoping you could address the decision
to hold Camp Obamas [inaudible]
David Plouffe: Yeah, well. For those of you
who don't know, we started things called 'Camp
Obamas', where we invited people who had expressed
an interest in the campaign -- first, to come
to Chicago, and then, we did them regionally
to learn about organizing.
We had, by the way, we had tens of thousands
of people who essentially were full-time campaign
employees, but weren't on our payroll, who
said, "I'm going to take four months or six
months off work. I'm going to quit my job."
They wanted to learn how to organize.
And in the beginning, it was a big challenge.
You know, one of the reasons we won was our
focus.
We were focused on Iowa, and to a lesser extent,
New Hampshire, South Carolina, Nevada.
Well, there's 46 other states.
And even in the beginning, when we were pretty
small, we had a really robust, excited group
of supporters that grew.
And so, honestly, it was as much challenge
as opportunity to figure out what to do with
all these people.
By the way, the thing we'd always say, and
it would frustrate people.
"I want to help. I'm in St. Louis. What can
I do?"
"You can get ten more people to sign up on
the website."
And sometimes people think that was a blow-off.
Nothing was more important to us than growing
that list, because those were people that
we could convert to volunteers and donors
and precinct captains.
But people wanted to do more than that.
And so, we said, "Well, let's do these 'Camp
Obamas'."
And they just flourished.
So we had all these people that understood
how we organized, that we valued it.
See, that's really important.
I started off as a canvasser, a field staffer,
organizer.
Back then, we were called 'field scum.' You
know, it wasn't something that was really
-- it was kind of secondary to the campaign.
Everybody, I think, who helped us in the campaign
understood that we valued organizing, largely
because the president valued organizing.
So these Camp Obamas were a great way to surface
great talent.
So we hired a lot of our staff out of them.
We had a lot of people who said, "I'm going
to go give you a month on the ground." and
they were better schooled.
And you know, it made a huge difference for
us.
I mean, listen, I told the very young kids
who were part of our campaign how spoiled
they were.
Because to be involved in a campaign like
this, when anything was possible, because
of the people, okay?
Virginia. We wanted to talk to 20 percent
of the Republican electorate, because we thought
they might beat for us.
Every Independent in certain demographic areas.
Every Democrat.
Try and register every African-American voter.
Every young person.
Think about that. We could do that, human
being to human being.
So our campaign really was the art of the
possible.
And I think -- because of the people.
And we had good strategies, and I think we
pushed the envelope in a lot of ways, but
it was all about the people.
So the Camp Obamas -- and, by the way, it
tells you that, most of the people who came
to the campaign came through a digital portal.
And we communicated with them digitally.
And many of them organized on our social networking
site.
They raised money on our site.
But still, most of the key persuasion work
was done offline.
And interestingly enough, we ended up building
kind of a real estate empire out there.
We had thousands and thousands of offices
and 90 percent of our supporters lived within
ten minutes of an Obama office -- I mean,
everywhere.
And the reason we did that is, we found that
people wanted to have that connection.
Even if they made most of their phone calls
for us at home, they wanted to be able to
go in at the office.
And so, it was an important lesson that, even
as this is going to become -- politics will
become more and more technologically-driven,
I think you've got to have that component.
Because there still is no substitute for human
being looking a human being in the eye.
And this is something we could measure.
The door knocking that was done was always
much more productive than the phone calling
or the e-mailing.
Doesn't take a rocket scientist to know why,
you know?
You develop a relationship with someone and
you actually, you know?
You have longer conversations, more intense
conversations.
You elicit more information, and you build
a relationship.
And I'd say, even in Iowa, you know one's
phenomenon, our supporters -- many of them
who went through Camp Obama -- were so dogged.
It was like, you know, windchill below zero
in Iowa the last three or four days.
And we were all over the streets.
And you know, we weren't seeing our opponents
as much.
And some Iowa caucus-goers who were undecided
said, "I've decided to be for you, because
if you're nuts enough to be out here in this
weather, you clearly believe in this guy."
And even a small thing like that made a big
difference in the caucuses.
Yes.
Q Talking about metrics around things that
were here in 2008 election, in 2012 is going
to be really, really context where do you
think it's going to apply?
And where do you think it's not going to apply?
David Plouffe: Well, you know, we're not -- largely
through a presidential dictate -- not really
focused on '12, because you know, I think
that's right.
We got big problems, and you don't want to
be thinking about the election.
So I just have some kind of topline, macro
thoughts.
That campaign will be different in many ways,
and I don't think we know today How it will
be different.
The one commonality will be -- because any
effort Barack Obama is involved in will have
people at its core -- we will of course, want
to get people involved as we did.
And have the grassroots play such an important
role.
You know, the issue environment -- where the
economy is -- could determine which states
are more easily won or lost.
I know that technology is going to change
in fundamental ways.
And it's not, you know, I don't know if it's
12, could be -- could be '16, could be '20.
But it won't be too long that people will
look back at what we did in this campaign,
sending people e-mails they opened up on their
desktop or their laptop -- it's going to be
like Jurassic Park.
And so, we know that things are heading to
a place where more and more people are going
to do most of their e-mails and their video-watching
and sharing and searching for information
on their mobile device.
And I salivated that, because I think about
what had happened if 30 percent of our supporters
were reading our e-mails, getting our videos,
while they were walking around in restaurants
sitting here -- the ability to share that
instantaneously, to look at an ap and say,
"Hey look, the Obama office down the street
is short four canvassers?
I'll go canvas."
I mean, things like that just are going to
make participatory democracy even greater.
Now of course, the atmospherics of that election,
the history's been made.
And you've got a record to run on.
So it'll be different in many ways in that
regard.
But I know that one thing we'll be committed
to is running a grassroots campaign.
And my hope is that the Republicans study
that book and the 2008 election.
Because I assure you, we will have some new
chapters in store.
One more. Yes, sir.
No Sarah Palin questions. This is amazing.
[laughter]
Q Going back to the nomination, back to February/March
2008, [inaudible]
David Plouffe: Well, it's something I write
about in the book.
You know listen, this was not a fun way to
live, but we lived all of 2007 and we used
the first 35 days of 2008 with the full knowledge
that she was in all likelihood the winner,
that we had one narrow path, and that a lot
of things had to go right for us to win.
And I think that made us a very, very good
campaign.
We knew what we're up against.
So we win Iowa -- we didn't think we were
going to win.
We thought that was our -- essentially the
gate had been open.
And we'll see how far we can run.
But it was an opportunity then, to see if
we could begin to erode her leads.
We lose New Hampshire.
I think the biggest surprise of the entire
two years is that Barack Obama is the President
of the United States having lost a New Hampshire
primary.
I can assure you that was not in our playbook
about how to win.
And I think there was a lot of commentary
and a lot of people believed that the race
was then over -- that we had had our moment
in Iowa, but order had been restored, Hillary
came back, and won New Hampshire.
And I think some of that commentary is a little
extreme, but it's hard for me to argue with
it.
We were up against it then.
And the way we were able to recover is we
got -- and I spent a lot of time in the book
writing about South Carolina.
South Carolina, for a lot of reasons, gave
us more momentum than we could have realized,
coupled with an endorsement from Senator Kennedy
two days later that was more about what he
said than that he endorsed -- you know, linking
us to his slain brothers in a way he had never
done before, taking on some of the attacks
that were being made against us, in relation
to what they had said about his brother Jack,
was just enormously powerful.
And then, we go into February 5th, including
California.
And that was the day we lived in fear of,
the entire campaign.
She's sitting there with leads of 15, 20,
30 points.
We couldn't campaign in those states, because
there was ten days between South Carolina
and February 5th.
We did a half day in California.
And we knew we needed time on the ground to
win.
And we had raised more money than we thought,
so we were doing some advertising, but it
was still pretty modest.
And we knew we had better organization, which
is something we didn't expect in all of states,
including the ones we lost.
But would that be enough?
And remarkably, because I think -- and you
know, this is hard for our supporters in California
-- we didn't come bunker in out here, even
though it was a big state.
We knew we were going to lose it, but we thought
the delegates were going to be pretty close,
so we went to places like Idaho and Kansas
and Georgia and tried to run up the margin,
because in our primary system, the only way
to experience a real delegate yield is to
win a landslide.
And so, February 5th -- my favorite story,
New Jersey -- it's a big state. She wins by
11 points.
It offers like, 130 delegates. She only nets
11 out of the equation.
So the delegates are pretty even.
Little, tiny Idaho only offers 18 delegates,
but we won an 80 to 20.
We get 15 delegates, she gets three.
We gain more delegates out of winning Ohio/Idaho,
than she did in New Jersey.
She wins California, you know, by nine points.
We actually won Election Day, by the way,
but we got clobbered in the early vote.
She nets, I think, 33 delegates.
We erase that in Colorado in Minnesota, and
that's the story of February 5th.
We cobbled together a bunch of smaller states.
So the first time I thought that, all things
being equal, Barack Obama should win the nomination
was -- to use a term that gained some notoriety
in the campaign -- about 3 a.m. on February
6th.
And then, we went off and ran 11 victories
off in a row.
And we gained an upper hand.
And then, because I made some mistakes and
we didn't close well, we ended up losing the
Texas primary, and the campaign dragged on
for three months after that.
But the outcome was known.
Unless something cataclysmic happened, we
were going to win.
So that's when it was.
It was when we survived the day that was the
greatest threat to our candidacy.
And, you know, after New Hampshire, the other
thing I find most remarkable.
You got to remember, you guys -- well, you
don't have many competitors.
You have some. [laughter]
But, you know, politics is a competitive enterprise.
John McCain had three additional months.
Think about that. He was the nominee on March
4th, because we didn't win Texas.
We didn't clinch our nomination till June
3rd.
We gave him three months.
And we figured, "Great. He's going to get
better organized in the battleground states.
He's going to be far ahead of us strategically.
He's going to develop an incisive economic
message.
He's going to separate from Bush.
And he's going to be ready to unleash holy
hell on us when we come out of the primary."
And none of that happened.
And it was a feat of enormous political malpractice.
[laughter]
Because, if they had used those three months
differently -- see, it doesn't seem like a
big deal now.
People say, "Plouffe, who cares you lost the
Texas primary? You won."
But, you think about that.
I mean, that night I thought, "We have really
screwed the pu chair. We might have just caused
ourselves the presidency."
Because we actually thought McCain was going
to end up running a very good campaign.
He was a dangerous candidate for a number
of reasons to us.
And so, that was what's frustrating in March.
We knew how that story was going to end, but
we couldn't turn the page.
And we assumed McCain was going to be gallivanting
across the country, building all sorts of
advantages on us.
And thankfully, from our perspective, he did
not.
Well, you guys are great to listen and to
let me prattle on here.
But hopefully, you'll enjoy the book and stay
involved in politics if you got involved.
And change is hard, but you know, if we all
do the right thing over the next three or
four years.
You know, listen, you guys are going to lead
the country.
Many of you are leading it now.
But, you know, I always tell folks, you know,
"You're going to inherit this very, very soon.
And you know, if we don't do the right things
now to strengthen and stabilize this country,
it's going to make our job much harder."
So, hopefully, we can do some smart things
over the next few years.
So in many ways, you are already leading,
but you are going to be leading formally in
the not-too-distant future.
You know, things -- we can hand off a little
bit better situation so you can really make
it flourish and grow.
So, thanks for being here.
>> [Clapping]